[Music]
we need to respond to this attack in
America as one United people with Force
purpose and
determination but the current
politically correct response cripples
our ability to talk and to think and act
clearly the Obama Administration with
the support of Hillary Clinton and
others has also damaged our security by
restraining our intelligence they have
put political correctness above Common
Sense above your safety and above all
else I refuse to be politically correct
2016 presumptive GOP nominee Donald
Trump earlier today warning about the
dangers of political correctness
following the terrorist attack in
Orlando Florida joining us now with
reaction is the president of act for
America Bri Gabriel and the director of
jihad watch Robert Spencer thank you
both for being with us you know Hillary
Clinton takes money from Saudi Arabia
year uh uh cutter and brunai Brit let's
see they have the death penalty in some
instances for gay people she claims to
be a champion of gay rights they treat
women horribly they can't drive they're
told how to dress Etc all the things
we've talked about how does she get away
with that taking millions of dollars not
criticizing those countries till today
and taking their money and never on
record criticizing
them well she cannot criti ize them
because she needs more of their money
remember she needs their support so she
has a vested interest in not criticizing
them because then they'll be upset with
her so she is putting her interest and
the interest of her foundation and her
family before the national interest of
the United States and that is Criminal
well and certainly and Robert she's
putting her political interest her
foundation interest certainly above the
rights of women and the mistreatment of
women and the mistreatment of gays and
lesbians oh there's no doubt about that
what's up ever yes I mean she's been
completely self- serving throughout her
political career but when it comes to
any kind of feminist concern for the
mistreatment of women in Islamic law or
under in Islamic countries under Sharia
she has never shown the slightest
interest and never said a word about it
Brit there's a conflict of civilizations
here we're at a Crossroads Sharia law is
the direct it's the antithesis of our
Democratic Republic our constitutional
republic so if somebody comes from a
country and they grow up under Sharia
how can you ever ascertain whether or
not they really want the freedoms we
have or if they want to indoctrinate and
bring their religion and their theocracy
with
them well we just have to look at their
actions you know Sean youve heard me say
this before actions speak louder than
words there are those who come to our
country and they do assimilate and you
can tell they are assimilating how do
you
tell well those who are devout obviously
their actions uh show where they stand I
mean look at this guy in Florida Omar
his co-workers complained that he is
radicals his co-workers turned him to
the FBI in 2013 because he was trying to
recruit them uh into Isis the FBI
interviewed him twice in 2013 right
Robert same question well look the thing
is that these mosques are not being
monitored and they need to be they're
teaching this kind of hatred and
violence and political correctness and
this willful ignorance the denial that
Hillary represents is only aiding and
abetting it the Islamic Center of Fort
Pierce that that the shooter from
Orlando went to a few years ago they had
a Jihad suicide bomber joined the
Islamic State and blew himself up in
Syria and he went to the same MK why was
that not mque not investigated and shut
down at that point then the people in
the Orlando club might be alive today
well that's pretty deep and profound and
this guy apparently knew that guy right
absolutely yes yeah all right and by the
way Sean there has been three different
studies uh how the uh radical Muslims
America are radicalized in the mosque
seven out of 10 mosques in America are
radicalized came from uh Afghanistan 90
he supported the Taliban and 99% of
those people coming from there support
Sharia but thank you both for being with
us coming up we're going to have more
Hannity right after this quick break
stay with
us